i learned that
it's really challenging to take
something that's in your head or on the
page
and
translate it to what's on the screen
there's a real craft in that that is the
art of directing uh in my in my humble
opinion and so like that just takes
practice right like that's just trial
and error of having a vision
doing what you think is needs to be done
to execute that vision and then seeing
if it worked seeing what the finished
product looks like um
so that takes that takes time you know
my most recent short though
it's called harmony and golden and it it
wound up looking better than what i had
in my mind and so like when i achieved
that i felt okay i'm ready to to do a
feature and um
and yeah i got into the nft space about
a year ago my genesis drop was in
october which was a series of 100
photographs that i took at the madonna
inn hotel
amazing
location and uh those photos inspired
the screenplay for what's now going to
be my first feature film and also for
the photos of keepers of the inn right
we did we took almost 3 400 photos
during the rehearsal process of that
movie and drop them as nfts
as you know as as a as a means to get
the film funded and as well as trigger
some other grants to onboard more women
into the nft space more film female
filmmakers
i love that hold on one second uh
everybody who's listening dustin do we
have some audio problems on my end
interesting give me one second
how about now
how about now
i might have to stop it
do do we want to do that or yeah let's
just keep it going can you guys hear me
okay we'll just keep going awesome let's
keep that part in the podcast i want
everybody to know everything i believe
in full transparency big shout out to
justin and seth for helping us julie
let's keep it going so
let's talk about
photography nfts so i think
one of the things
that
attracted me to your project is i was
just going down rabbit holes of people
that were in photography
and we're active in the nft community i
saw you very active then phil toronto
our mutual homies like i love julie i
was like okay i gotta actually get
around to really pic if you're a friend
of phil's you're a friend of mine i
gotta really look at this and then when
i kind of finally had a second to
breathe and look at it i'm like wait a
minute this is also tied into movie
making i'm very hot on
music and books being funded through nft
projects of course i believe in scripts
movies and television shows being the
same
um
but before we get into that film stuff i
want to talk about just photography nfts
what's your take do you agree with me
that there's
a real potential obviously when we look
at the real world
art art
is a bigger market than photography art
but photography art's a son of a [ __ ]
it's big there are people there's you
know i [ __ ] spent a ton of money on
an andy warhol [ __ ] kodak little you
know like little
you know
of my of kareem abdul-jabbar like and
then you know there's obviously uh my my
my um
dear friend from college uh dustin
bingham his father was the legendary
howard bingham who was one of the iconic
black photographers and i know his work
so
you know a can you educate me because
i'm not that educated on how big the
real world photography collecting world
is or maybe that's not your expertise
and b
what do you think about photography nft
because you could have fundraise you
could have done this for the movie not
through photography you could have done
it through art or drawings or doodle
nfts
take us home on that yeah i mean the
choice to to do this
with photography was organic because
this the screenplay was based off of
photos so the whole
process of this has been quite organic
and
photography i don't know about
photography collecting in real life to
be honest because as a professional
photographer my work is more in
photographing for brand campaigns and uh
product stuff and so and you know all
album art and stuff that's like a little
bit more um client-based but um but i
definitely think that that this
explosion of photography nfts
is real and is going to continue its
trajectory
because i think there's a real when it
comes to one-of-one photography
in my opinion there's no real need for
utility it stands alone as this captured
moment this sort of piece of fine art
and i don't
think that there's another medium in the
space that does it that well um that's
coming from me who obviously my photos
for keepers of the in comes with utility
but the only reason that those photos
come with utility is because it's
again organic it's like i'm trying to
bridge that gap between film and
photography so um i don't know there's
just something like as a collector even
like i've collected
tons of photography and there's just
something so
magical about seeing an image online and
being able to earn that moment and so i
i think that it's just really we're
poised for photography
to continue to explode have you have you
collected physical photography in your
life or no
i mean yeah sure i have like not in a
not from like a fine art gallery or i've
i've not dropped a bunch of my i've
spent more money on photography nfts
than i have on in real life uh
photography but but i i love having it
in my place but i don't know it's i
sometimes at night i'll just scroll
through my wallet and look at my
beautiful
photography collection i it's
there's something so gratifying about it
i agree i think people are really
underestimating the digital world
they're like you can't touch it i'm like
guess what
i can look at it in my bed on my phone
and not have to get up and put on the
lights in my apartment and see my art
like it's it's like there's there's pros
and cons to everything there's
i i love physical but i love digital and
it's a game of and not or
um speaking about and and not or
let's talk about that so you sell out
do
you start getting a lot of random emails
over the next day or a week yeah i mean
it's still it was three weeks ago today
and it's uh
it's still things are still pouring in
but yeah for sure
it exploded um it was incredibly
invalidating and exciting i put i put
almost 3 400 of my photos out and you
know as a creator how vulnerable of an
experience it is to put your artwork out
like that and so
the responses
have been amazing
sure be because it's the first film
funded and also because of the utility
but mainly the thing that's felt the
best is just people's response to the
artwork and how it's inspiring them and
interesting situations where do people
where do people find it on open seat
other platforms
it's oh keepers of the n.art is our
website which can lead you to open c for
the secondary sales um
yeah for everybody it's keepers of the
end on openc and it's verified um if
you're looking for what it is so
are people
reaching out with the main question of
how did you do this
yeah we've yeah definitely have gotten a
lot of people interested in
picking my brain and wanting to know how
they can apply it to their film projects
for sure that's that's but i'm happy to
talk about that i love talking about the
process it was so fun
super stressful but super fun to put
this
drop together and i think it's a model
that can really work for a lot of people
so i'm
like i've answered every every dm that
i've gotten and had a bunch of follow-up
calls i just i want to spread the word
you know
i get bombarded by people asking me
gary this stuff is so expensive ethereum
like you know what's a good value
nft i think the photography space in
general
is a good value nft with the right
projects i mean julie has to go out and
make
this
matter to people you know obviously it's
going to have this historic nature being
one of the
first if not the first i just haven't
done my homework but it seems like it to
fund this way and sell out so that might
make it collectible but
um
like every project the artist
and the company need to make people care
so when is the movie how does the movie
play out like when does it come how does
it go yeah so we're shooting in uh we're
shooting this summer gotta we have to
pick an exact date but at some point
towards the end of this summer and then
probably around this time next year
everything will be
nice and finished and we'll do a big
event and screening in la where people
can come or holders can come or live
stream in uh we'll set up something so
you're probably thinking through a lot
right now of like the 3000 plus people
that are holding
what the benefits are going to be
i mean there's
it's there's extensive utility that now
we're just kind of
like
now we're just figuring out when to
trickle this the utility out and what
our sort of benchmarks are
for everything but the main thing that
we're doing which i started two weeks
ago is uh every two weeks we're going to
do a town hall where i'm going to update
the community on where i'm at in the
creative process
and just be candid and share share
share my vision and hopefully
get some of the art collectors to weigh
in and let me know their thoughts and um
and help kind of guide me to make the
best possible version of this film that
that i can with the community's support
what are you worried about
uh what am i worried about
i mean i guess
i guess this is the volatility of
ethereum i don't i that that would be
like i mean um did you convert the
ethereum into usd so you can start doing
your thing yeah we took yeah we took
what we needed to be able to execute the
pressing utility items um
but yeah i mean that's that's a thing
and i i believe wholeheartedly in nfts
and i and
cryptocurrency and i'm
i don't you know i think it's a long
term thing that's going to last but um
just kind of the you know
worrying about
mainstream's aversion to it and and um
the conflict that comes with that but
that's honestly such a minor thing and
when it comes to the project i i
i truly it's like i wake up every
morning feeling so inspired and excited
um
final thoughts what did we not get to in
this fun little interview anything you
want to leave people with
um yeah i mean just
again just
stating that
as someone who's now
hopefully paved this way for more people
to come like please just
get in touch with me i want to be able
to how do they get in touch with you on
uh on twitter at julie underscore pacino
um
the nft community everyone's so
accessible and that's what i love about
it and so i just i i'm i'm the same way
and i love talking about the process and
geeking out over movies and helping
provide whatever insight that i can so i
i just love connecting with people and i
um
you know i i hope if anyone listening or
anyone that sees my art likes the art
and wants to talk about it like please
get in touch with me because that's what
i live for honestly
julie thanks for being on the show
thanks for having me gary